for the first time in two months
Madrid's restaurants and coffee shops
are back in business
for now this is the new normal only
outside seating is permitted chairs
cleaned after every customer and city
employees around the square disinfecting
the area during the time of this
pandemic some customers say they are
willing to adapt I spent the entire
lockdown period alone so this finally
offers a bit of social life it is a bit
odd with the social distancing and
everything but I've really missed it and
Spain's Canary Islands locals are out
enjoying the warm weather but notably
missing our terse tourism accounts for
more than 12% of Spain's economy
businesses are eagerly waiting for July
when the country is scheduled to reopen
its borders to international visitors
it's essential to have tourists back in
our businesses during the lockdown we
worked fairly well with local clients so
far we're happy with things including
the easing of restrictions Greece is
also trying to salvage his tourism
industry reopened coffee shops and
Athens are mostly empty with tourists
denied entry until mid-june visitors
spent more than nineteen billion dollars
in Greece last year but times have
changed last year at around this time we
had tourists and we were crowded now we
live a different reality the economic
crisis is going to be global
but in Greece we spent the last decade
dealing with the bailouts so the crisis
is going to be far worse for us in Italy
one of the hardest hit countries in
Europe Jem's reopened on Monday only
customers who booked in advance are
allowed into this gym in Rome but many
people have got used to doing their
exercises online this business like
other industries may have to change its
pre corona business plans in Berlin
reopen swimming pools must follow rules
of Hygiene and social distancing
it was pleasant above all I was
surprised that it wasn't as full as I
feared
only a certain number of people can get
in you have to basically swim in circles
the ease restrictions may be a relief
for thousands of Europeans but for
entrepreneurs it's yet another test of
whether their business will survive this
face of the lockdown
Patsy Lopez of the young al Jazeera